disgraced cycling superstar Lance
Armstrong stripped of his medals and out
of millions of dollars in endorsements
for years of alleged doping before
disgraced cycling great Lance Armstrong
disappears completely down whatever
hellhole is reserved for sanctimonious
former Kate Hudson boyfriends I'd like
to say a few words in defense of lance
and what he did the seven-time two of
the France winner might have overcome
testicular cancer being named lance and
or edible cameo and dodgeball a true
underdog story but he finally ran up
against the opponent that he just
couldn't beat reality after basically
everyone who's worked with him since he
first started racing tricycle said that
lance doped more than Gary Busey in
rehab the International Cycling Union
which oversees these things strict
armstrong of the seven titles and banned
him from the sport for life now his
corporate sponsors ranging from Nike to
oakley to anheuser-busch who once stood
strong behind him are going softer than
Liberace at a speculum convention
they've pulled their support of the
bipedal stud even the International
Olympic Committee is getting set to
strip him of his bronze medal from the
2000 games now at this rate the only
thing Lance is going to have left where
he's a garage full of yellow LIVESTRONG
bracelets but here's the point he was
just doing what every other top cyclists
has been doing forever I mean for
heaven's sake I'm pretty sure even the
kids and those big wheel commercials
were juicing and I mean that literally
they were all hopped up on high C and
Hawaiian Punch why should he be singled
out for being better at it than a bunch
of euro weenies who was still mad that
an unsophisticated American from Texas
no less was able to beat them with one
testicle tied behind his back if drugs
are being used by all athletes in a
given sport and there's no way to
effectively get rid of them doesn't it
make more sense to legalize them and
would level the playing field far more
than making winners pee in a cup the
minute they cross the finish line
instead we banish them to pharmaceutical
purgatory because we're uncomfortable
with the basic human urge to take drugs
to do better remember Rafael Palmeiro
the former baseball star who put up
incredible numbers even while wearing a
mustache straight out of south of the
border porn well Paul Merrill is just
one of four players to get 3000 hits and
smash
500 home runs but because he tested
positive for the same steroids that were
available to all his teammates the only
way he'll get into the Hall of Fame is
by waiting tables as it happens Palmeiro
didn't just do drugs to put more pop in
his louisville slugger he was also one
of the first celebrity endorsers of
Viagra precisely the sort of
performance-enhancing drug that just
about everyone's cake and more and more
did mrs. Palmero care that her husband
was swinging a bigger stick because of a
drug hell I'm guessing she probably
picked up the prescription to ride a
prozac Ritalin Adderall lipitor coffee
the occasional snort of heroin humans
are nothing if not drug-taking machines
and not in a Lindsay Lohan Charlie Sheen
sword away we take drugs to make
ourselves happier smarter and healthier
Lance Armstrong may have been lying all
those years about not taking drugs but
hate the line not the hormones after all
he wasn't doing anything that any of us
aren't doing every day and thank God and
Merck Pfizer and black so for helping us
to keep on keeping on like a long-haul
trucker with a thousand miles to go and
just five hours to get there we'll miss
you Lance and we'll forget you too
unless someone comes up with a new drug
for that 4recent TV I'm Kennedy
you